hi everybody
uh i think it's 4 p.m so we will we will
start the session
i hope everybody can hear me
perfect so welcome to today's session uh
as you may know uh we are doing a
practice asia and design singapore
council has partnered to bring you this
workshop
and as you know design singapore council
is the national agency here in singapore
uh which helps promote and develop the
design community and industry here
and um with that in mind today's session
is to look at thailand as a market
uh which is full of opportunities and
and potential challenges that um
that singaporean design firms could face
um and we have a
an exciting lineup of experienced
speakers from the thai
design industry will bring their their
insights from the ground
um to to discuss their experiences and
also
um how potentially singapore design
firms
should look at the market so but before
we go
to me introducing the speakers i would
just like to introduce myself i'm uday
paneker i'm the singapore country
manager for practice asia
and we're a regional management
consulting firm that has
been helping companies enter and expand
their presence in southeast asia
for over 25 years and i just want to
thank the design singapore council
for giving us this opportunity to work
with them and also to
all the speakers here today for their
time
keeping in mind that everybody uh has
only an hour for this session
uh and with the busy schedules and
possibly zoom fatigue we want to make
sure that
um everything is uh is done within the
hours so
uh just wanted to take everybody through
a quick uh
agenda for today so um just a few house
rules
uh only these speakers and presenters
will have access to
the video and audio uh we'll have this
session for one hour uh
each speaker shall have 15 minutes each
and we'll conclude this session today
with
a 15-minute question and answer session
for the audience uh which will be done
on zoom chat
so please feel free to uh to ask your
questions uh
on the question answer chat feature in
zoom
and uh the design singapore council
has something called the business of
design program and specific information
for singaporean firms that want to get
more information on that
and we will also be touching upon a few
of the grants that enterprise singapore
has
for smes here who are looking to
internationalize in the region
and we'll conclude with a small poll for
everybody
and uh go on to the question and answer
session
so today's presentations will be brought
to you by kun chutayama cintupan
director of the creative economy agency
of thailand followed by
kun sarin rat and mr marine beige who is
the founder of lions design works
so i will introduce you to each speaker
prior to their to their 15-minute
presentation
and um and then we will we will have the
final question answer session
at the end so without any further ado um
i would like to introduce
uh kunchu tayaves who has been uh
who's an architect and an educator based
in bangkok
uh for several years and with a master
of architecture from columbia university
and a bachelor of science
um uh in in architecture technology from
new york institute of technology
he's also currently the adjunct faculty
at chulalongkorn university's
international program of design and
architecture
and he has been an associate professor
previously with the new york institute
of technology as well as
a faculty at tamasa design school and he
has taught
at various other universities such as
yale columbia pratt institute
and the parsons school of design
kunchitayavas has a
he focuses on a research-led approach to
design and
is the founder of several award-winning
design practices and social enterprises
such as site-specific architecture
research design for disasters
and fab cafe bangkok so um
i think i will i will let you take the
reins from here
um and give us a bit of an insight on
thailand
in general from a design industry
perspective so please feel free to
to share your screen okay thank you
okay i hope you can see my you can see
my screen which is fine
yes um okay um
well this is going to be a very direct
um presentation
uh we're not going to be talking about
design we're basically going to talk
about
what you need to know about thailand in
order to
target the market near the design market
in thailand
basically what we're going to be talking
about is geography
creative industries and market because
um
for the reasons that geography is varied
so much in thailand
and as you know as uh thailand creative
and design center or
creative economy agency uh we have
centers
we uh in three regions at the moment and
we'll have four eventually
and we have to do that because you know
the geography is different the culture
is different
in all different locations and there are
very specific uh needs
uh in different regions uh we're going
to be talking about overall abroad of
what we see as great youth industries in
thailand and how singapore can actually
enter thai market
um geography as we know um
you know thailand's divided into five
uh region there's a central plain
there's the north northeast the east
and the south um
in all this location we have currently
tcdc in bangkok which is our
headquarters for creative economy agency
the second branch is tccc in chiang mai
the fourth one is tcdc congen which
where i am currently here that at the
moment
and then we will be opening tcs in some
clients southern thailand in 2022
also we will have a a project called dc
common which is
a smaller version of tcdc in the east in
about three years
um if you look at our geography you can
see
that you know bangkok and the central
plain
is completely different from the
mountainous north
and it's also even though it's also a
plane but
in the northeast it's actually a plateau
um
so konkan it's right in the middle here
and that's where i'm sitting at the
moment
in the north our center is in chiang mai
which is a very popular tourist
destination
of course you know bangkok and then we
pick
um to locate our southern brands
in in some in some cloud which is just
you know half an hour from fbi um it's a
capital of the province even though it's
smaller than fbi itself
um and these four locations speak
specifically
because a lot of them are center
of this region and also we pick them
because they all offers very unique
opportunities
in different locations for example
bangkok
is the center of the country it's
accepted that
you know bangkok is both the capital
the trade capital the financial capital
and also the port of the city so
bangkok has become too big and it's
basically
um
need there's a specific specific
requirement
you know for the bangkok and the central
plain itself
um in the mountainous area in chiang mai
um agriculture and and of course the
central plain
you know the industry the traditionally
smokers
more focused on agriculture as main
industry but now
you know being a developed country now
we do have a lot of
heavy industries that's happening around
bangkok and the central plain area
in chiang mai is completely different
because you know agriculture where
small farms you know instead of large
rice patties
so traditionally people have a lot more
time
so it's known to be a region where all
the crafts
are you know highly valued you know
traditional design where you know people
spend hours and hours
working on bamboo rods you know to make
baskets or to make furnitures um
and you know chiang mai you know being
the
largest city in the north within also in
the largest
kind of like plane you can see that it's
kind of like light green around chiang
mai
uh it's also kind of like there's you
know a center for
kind of like um craft and
you know craft industries you know also
content is different content is a
relatively
new city in terms of growth even though
it was founded 200 years ago
only grew about 60 years ago
and it was it grew because it decided
that
the northeast region needs a center for
government
and it was picked that konkan is center
enough
in the region you know to go anywhere in
the northeast
within a reasonable period of time by
car
and it's also connected to bangkok by
rail
in the old days and road
and sohan can kind of artificially
grow very rapidly in the first you know
20 years or so
that it was picked and
recently also it's become more of a
trading post
that because of the connection between
uh
currently it's just the road right but
then the north east
the east-west corridor and north south
corridor we all
from china down into riyadh
we also passed through congen
and the south of course it's a peninsula
and it's a port
and it's also mountainous and its
culture is completely different from the
other location because there's
very strongly tied to malayu culture and
and and malaysia um
and and and it's also created a unique
um
setting and all these different
you know graphic locations makes
completely different
sort of requirements
and needs that that you know a designer
in different locations need um you can
see this
i'm just taking a picture of showing the
picture of
basically agriculture is all different
region
this is the central plain you know it's
just flat
you know with uh of course some
mountains you know whatever it's very
flat
um this is the north you know it's
mountainous agriculture area
northeast even though it's a plateau so
it's also pretty flat but it's very airy
and very dry
because it's in the rainchad over most
of the year
and the south basically it's the wettest
you know region in thailand and
[Music]
agriculture there it's also different
so when we talk about creative
industries
um as you can see this is the
traditional
um sort of you know data
when we talk about industries in
thailand that
even though it used to agriculture used
to be the biggest
numbers on this graph
now it's very different it's that
service industry has become the biggest
income in thailand from tourism
from medic from medicine
from you know just
food and beverage in general and then
also heavy industries now play a major
role
and you can see that agriculture has
reduced quite significantly
now it's less than eight percent that
that agriculture is actually
a part of our gdp but um
so when we look at creative industries
we decide we
decide we divided it into 15
different segments into five groups
one is the co-creative original which
basically talks about
what we did you know in the old days
before we decided that
we what we thought of the word bridges
right so
it's basically handicraft music
traditional plays and performing arts
and there are also fine arts
and then the second group is called the
content and media group so basically
there's film and television
broadcasting printing and in software
industries
and the third one is um creative
services
which basically you know that's what
when we thought of
about design is what people think of it
originally that you know advertising um
different sort of design you know
graphic with a graphic design or
your illustration and uh architecture
and the fourth group is creative goods
and products so
in thailand mainly fashion industries
and
one thing that is slightly different
from other
creative industries in other in
different other countries that
the related industry is very important
to us
first is food second is
traditional thai medicine in parentheses
you know spa services
and then therefore the last one in this
15 group is the
cultural tourism
[Music]
as you can see that you know we have
tcdc in different branches
uh in different regions our focus from
in these regions are very different in
bangkok we talk about how design can
improve lives
being you know kind of like a very urban
area
center of the country you know big urban
space
and you know the the main goal
of that center is basically to talk
about
how what can design do for you
in the north east you know just like
what i said before
we talk about crafts and we've been
talking about craft for the past six
years
um north east we talked about potentials
and culture
so basically is entertainment industries
you know music and film um it's
food being the largest producers of
food sources in thailand the northeast
and very unique catholic food culture
there
and the fourth one is the weaving
industries which
grew up out of necessity island culture
is
designed in the northeast tends to be
doing things just enough it wasn't doing
doing things for the beauty unlike the
north
northeast region wouldn't be spending
you know a day
um trying to round the bamboo into the
perfect strand you try to make a basket
they would just cut up bamboo and leave
it and that would be
the appreciation of doing things just
enough
functional and then in the south
we will be talking about creativity's
true heritage because
of the idea of being multicultural so
we we want to talk about you know kind
of different cultures how the
cultures work together and with all
these different locations we have
created creative districts
right a lot of them surrounding our
center
most of them a few of them are not
like chilean group here district
district in bangkok it's basically the
center is ccc bangkok
and it has been very successful as a
model
to carry this creative district to try
to find a way to apply some of the
learning
into chiang mai creative district in the
north sea generative district in
congress where i am at the moment but si
chan is actually not where tcbc is
located
it's in the center of town where the old
trade
area used to be but now the old trade
trade area is dying
and then in the south uh some class
it's in the hotel area where tcdc is on
the fringe of that district
[Music]
so from
from the creative district we also have
a
event to celebrate um you know the
region
so basically the design week and the
creative festival is created so that
each year
all the designers all the creators and
tcdc itself are able to celebrate what
we do in the past year so ching my
design week was our first design week
and it's been going on for six years
bangkok design week will be held its
fourth year
event which actually rescheduled
about four months after it was supposed
to open
uh next month may uh in two months in
may
and inside creative festival will be the
first festival in uh
uh design festival design uh that will
be held in july
and then some crazy festival will be in
august
of next year after our center is open
so you can see you know the image of our
celebration
how you know how people would come
together and basically show what they've
done in the past
um you know being kind of like the
traditional design week you know in
chiang mai where
people come and gather in the region
in the city and also bangkok design we
you know where different issues of city
life are discussed
each year uh like the last last year in
we talked about resilience and of course
kobe came
what we've learned so what we've done in
uh in this time we were we some of it
were able to adapt
um into this corporate situation this
year and
for this year we'll talk about
resurgence of possibilities
and and so
you know if you can i don't know if that
will be open yet but please join
me if the water is open but design
creative festival is slightly different
instead most to decide
most design festival will bring people
into the city
beside creative festival as you can see
we
we use the name of the region rather
than the city itself
we don't use the word design and we use
the word creative
and instead of we use we use the name
festival
because we want to be more open isaan
being a very big region and there's no
real center
so we cannot call it content design we
can expect
the people everyone to come and receive
at the center of the state of the region
so
it's a declarative festival it's about
coming to again
and then you go somewhere else and that
will be a different sort of design
pistol that will happen
this year
so last issue i think it's the most
important and that's why we're here
market if you want to work in thailand
what should we be talking about i think
the main focus
for design in thailand for this next few
years will be
uh un sustainable development goal
and i think everyone knows this and
everyone
is trying to work on this somehow or
another
but in thailand we've taken it quite
seriously
as a government policies and also as
a business policies if you want to be
in if you are a business in the stock
market in thailand
you have to meet these goals as you can
see with the ranking
the top 10 sustainable
winners are still european countries
japan is doing pretty well being number
which is the highest ranking for asian
country korea just
not so far behind at number 20. thailand
is kind of like in the
top third and the bottom of the top
third
at number 41 with 74.54
um singapore is still a bit down from
there but
um it's basically it's just a proof that
you know thailand we're taking it
uh this thing quite seriously but the
strength in thai market is that
and i think we all know that you know
somewhat already is that our design and
creativity is
quite strong we do have a very strong
handicraft
productions and we also have a very
strong
production in term of mass production
activities
what can singapore offer i think with
singapore strength is in terms of
financial
technologies innovation
and research and if a designer a
singaporean designer wants to break into
thailand
i think it will be very um
to and to meet the needs in most thai
companies basically to bring the
research base based
innovation and technologies into a thai
market
and by doing that
um you will you will definitely be
basically you you what was i gonna say
but and basically technology innovation
is the basic requirement of most thai
companies
i think you know after all
this presentation i think singapore
have a very good setting to enter thai
market
as you know a center of innovation in
asia and now anyway
so i think i'll end my presentation here
and thank you great
thank you so much for for those for
those insights it was really interesting
to see how you
divide thailand into different
geographies and and the different
opportunities and
styles of designs are the cultural
implications of
that so thank you so much for for your
time
um and for any everybody else um
the attendees um if in case you missed
it conchotives is the director of the
creative economy agency of thailand
which works very closely with the
the thailand creative design center the
tcdc
so um that was um that was a great
presentation and thank you very much for
giving us that that the general
information
so our next speaker is kun sarin rat
who is uh principal at the uh
design worldwide partnership of thailand
the dwp
company she joined uwp as a designer
in 2004 before becoming a partner and
also a creative director at the firm in
2006.
her she has a extensive experience in in
terms of her project portfolio with uwp
where it has ranged from or work with
clients in the retail hospitality and
healthcare sector
as well as the residential community and
the workplace segments
some of our major clients include hsbc
ibm cadres and johnson and johnson
she has a bachelor of arts in interior
design and a master of arts in
integrated
marketing from emerson college in boston
us and she's also affiliated with the
international interior design
association
as well as the american institute of
architects i hope that was a good brief
description concerning rad i will give
you the flow thank you so much
thanks i'll start sharing my screen now
yes please
okay can you see my screen yes yes we
can okay
so why don't i just get started um i
have a lot of slides like i've mentioned
earlier but i'll go through
each one one of them quite quickly um
sure so this is our location so dwp
we are local but international so we
have a large office in bangkok
and these are our other office locations
you've done my background so that's done
um today with the singapore design
council i just wanted to bring you some
inside um useful tips for interior
design whether it be
lifestyle community or work and also
collaborations that we've done in the
past
with um foreigner and
local design firms and suppliers and
opportunities moving forward for the
time singapore market so that's what
i'll touch base on
so first and foremost we wanted to
understand the risk and uncertainty with
the
current situations of the pandemic so
each of these sectors have been affected
due to the covet pandemic that we've
been over the past
year so in terms of residential we're
looking to realign the price
remodel products workplace obviously
is you know turning to a huge change
to reshape the future of the environment
of the offices
and retail is going virtual as all you
all know
hotels are more focusing on
guest experience hygiene sanitaries and
also refocusing on tenants
industrial um you know resilient demand
um and the market potential in thailand
for architectural
and interior so the the strategy is to
you know build a green concept
so there's several certifications that
you can get through the
government partnership and mergers
opportunities with
international companies and branded a
lot of japanese
firms have moved into thailand to
partner with some of the real estate's
clients
and the actuals is just the cost
benefits of trade-offs
direct asset access to opportunities and
the
trade fair and the key events industry
in the
asean region
so the new normal in thailand market but
i believe this goes the same to our
asia-pacific market as well
so in terms of landlords and developers
again we're seeing a lot of global
partnerships
we have a lot of semi-indoor outdoor
spaces hygiene cleanliness focused
retails we're seeing a lot of pop-up
pop-ups and kiosks
shorter lease terms smaller space
required in e-commerce
for consumers it's a lot of online
presence and premium services
and products at home
so convenience some of the design
challenges
is um a lot of it has been due to
social distancing so physical distancing
circulations of patterns
and spatial contexts this is some of the
post pandemic design solutions
um the main ones are you know health
hygiene
touchless experience we're seeing a lot
of the touch list equipment now
work from anywhere the idea of things
5g is coming great outdoor experiences
and smart living
[Music]
some of our residential projects i'll
show
later but these are the trends for the
residential market
so home is a sanctuary bringing a sense
of comfort stability and solace
flexibility and multi-purpose areas um
less we see less of fixed joinery and
more of the loose furniture
sustainable sustainability in materials
specifications and a lot of
natural inspired tones and coloring so
this is the elements that we see for the
future homes and beyond so
multi-functional spaces
a lot of vintage and artsy decorations
bold
printed wallpapers spa grade bathrooms
and mini bar everywhere zoom rooms
some of the elements that we've always
put into our project now
um and um
so this is just to recap to realign
prices and expectations
targeted customer experience and new
lifestyle we're focusing now on
low rise housing developments town homes
and single housing
out outer skirt not so much in the cbd
and then we have selective ultra market
continues to
perform for the super ultra luxury
market so these are the penthouses in
the cbd areas larger units
and the drawbacks is the foreign buyers
you know we still need them to sustain
our real estate economy
so the product of in the spotlight is of
course ultra luxury
um you know optimizing price more
functions and customizations
and then we have leads back investment
options so real estate
are giving more options in terms of
investments
to their customers now some of the ultra
luxury
and super luxury projects that we've
done over the past
year um so some of these are very recent
um so we've done the santibari residence
this is house number two
it was selling for 20 million dollars
u.s dollars
and following the uh pandemic
they have remastered planted the whole
complex and made
the floor plan or footprint
uh much smaller and they are selling it
now for under 10
million us dollars so these are the
newer
versions of house number five is a newer
version as you can see
it um graduates from the very deep and
dark tone
um you know more um
senior sophisticated mature
into something that's more young and fun
dynamic
open so this is
you can say the post pandemic interior
design for homes
more natural neutral colors but very
fun and bold at the same time
this is another project that we've done
the architect
is fosters and partners we've been
working with them
from the office in london so this is the
wisdom
forest yeah and
in thailand so a lot of very natural
materials some semi-outdoor areas
fun spaces for the kids communal area
flexible flexible facilities
um so this is another
so there's three towers all together
this is the lobby of the third tower
which is a pet friendly
um apartment so this is the
show suite that was done and not yet
officially launched
but has had some vip previews over the
past couple of months
another project this is in front of the
met on saton road
125 saton a new developer um
but again you can see the the
how we bring the natural light into all
of our spaces a lot of garden areas
again the materialistic is very true to
its
nature so a lot of timber use marbles
and again quite light bright and airy
a lot of facility spaces for the
users and this is the unit itself
sales gallery will launch in a couple of
months
this is ashton round before it's
very they're looking for something
that's very
light and bright and neutral again some
of the new projects theme and trend
moving forward
salon and spa inside the apartment some
co-working spots
the next sector is hospitality so
hospitality
we have two things one is guest focus
and the other one is tenants focus
so we are seeing a lot of market for
locals now staycations delay in hotel
and apartment openings we have three
hotels that we finish the design but
have not been
opened yet due to the covet
increasing competition so there's
decreasing
expats in travelers and the rates have
been very competitive
good for locals and staycations um
and now you know for tenants that are
occupying
the public areas there's a discount of
flexibility in contracts
we're not seeing a lot of renovations uh
we we assume we have thought uh
mid of last year that there would be
tons of hotels wanting to renovate but
that's not the case
we're seeing so far as just some
refreshments and
upkeeping of the interior but no major
renovations
perception of hygiene is very important
they're really looking at the m
e systems and how to flush the airflow
contactless touchless equipment
multi-functionality social distancing
facilities
this is a short video that i will skip
but i'll share the link
with
so the id transfer hotels again
flexibility uses space circulations
integrating smart technologies
connectivities between indoor and
outdoor true design
providing well building certificate
certified environments
for specific spaces and then educating
consumers and guesses
some of our selective hotel projects
that the dwp has done over the past
two years uh this is w
in abu dhabi uae
so a lot of outdoor spaces private pods
in the outdoor spaces rooms with balcony
and
quite a spacious balcony with furnitures
um interactive lobby
you can see the chandelier on the left
side of the void those are led boxes and
it would
come alive at night
so that's very fun um flexible
furniture so these are modular seatings
that could be stacked
and uh um you know moved around
this is hotel jackson in melbourne it's
next to a retail mall so we have private
retail servicing for premium customers
on the side here the bar
again very bold colors large printed
artworks
but the room just keeping it very
neutral
and playing with some accent colors
this is westin hotel in myanmar
so you can see the you know similar
things there with some
of our residential projects as well this
is moxie and purdunam
a bit more fun and dynamic but the rooms
are quite
regular and easy to maintain
in terms of workplace we're looking to
reshape the future of workplace with
activity-based workplace and
high-performance workplaces
um you know looking for a new workplace
for the return of the post pandemic
flexibility um there's there will be a
lot of
upcoming office building supplies which
pressures the rental
growth and with the abw
and hpw model you'll see a reduce in
office space
requirements for attendance
so this is some of the office dynamics
work from home
work doing commute cafe
satellite offices meeting on demand
flexible spaces
and again the usage of office space has
decreased
by 30 percent
so what we're seeing now is smaller
office space
people are requesting more fully
furnished office space
co-facility and short-term rent cycles
um this goes through with not only
workplace but also for commercial
and education so schools
and retail you know we feel are
among these trends as well so focus on
well-being
with the need for safe human connection
environmental
transformation and technology is the
critical factor here
embracing the unconventional through
creativity and strategic thinking
focusing on design density geometric and
division
so with the covet workplace design we
also have to look
at the spaces and social distancing
so a lot of important role to designers
whether it's uh working stations or lift
lobbies circulations and corridors
and the changes obviously work from home
has become the new normal companies are
starting to give more
freedom to their employees reducing the
risk of direct contact
technology as we are what we're doing
now webinar instead of a full conference
touchless equipment some of our
selective workplace project this is
google office that we've done
um so a lot of space for the
staff different areas um this is
diageo's office which has
won an award last year
training facilities this is kbank
so very um bright light and open
no personal storage everything is locker
based
a lot of communal areas and they're
canteen
i'll just touch base very quickly on
healthcare and retail so
the trend of healthcare is you know a
lot of
outdoor indoor outdoor connectivities uh
no walls
hospitals are becoming more specialized
treating uh
more sick patients during the who needs
longer stays
outcome-based care patients caregivers
will
demand more of their physical and
virtual experiences
this is the aspen tree residence project
that we've done
so it's a high care for senior
aging society
again the design trends you see bold
prints
very natural color
palette here that we've used
um this is b grimm's it's a clinic that
we were thinking
um the client is thinking of roll out of
uh
to all of their factories so a new
project that we've
we've been doing um another another
project is the
again i'll share the link here it's
raksa
um we've done this is a collaboration
between
um sensory which is a large real estate
developer
bamura hospital and minor group
it's a wellness center at bangkorchow
area
so this was just completed
right before cold it hit so
they're not seeing a lot of uh expats or
um tauruses uh coming in yet but a lot
of
locals are using the facilities now
f b area fitness this is the hydro
and in terms of retail the outlook is
again focusing on innovation
um retailers look to create
a socially distanced experience using um
you know for cosmetics using augmented
reality to test
automatic checkouts um shifts in
behaviors
push for reform so um the stores are
focusing more on helping
not just hard selling anymore um
and then these are just the top 10 uh
design trends
for retails of 2021 and the future
so a lot of pop-ups that i've mentioned
before
comforting inviting home-like design in
some of the retail stores
um sophisticated and minimalist
minimalist merchandising
technology driven and natural light
the use of natural light so we're seeing
a drop
of uh retail um of about 15
over the past um almost two years
and it will just continue to drop as
we're not through the pandemic yet
um singapore will surely leverage
between its port and air hot facilities
for immediate access to international
markets while
thailand taps into its culture for local
crafts
design routes which are well established
um with pairing with the singapore
retailers in cross-border collaboration
i'm concerned thank you um i think we've
reached our 20 minutes
yep that was it oh perfect perfect
timing thank you so much
okay no thank you for giving us that um
you know
uh how thailand is refocusing when it
comes to interior design
um across retail air residential and
and uh and the workplace segments so
thank you for uh for giving us the
insights on that and how
dwp is working on those opportunities as
well so something for singaporean design
firms to also look at
is how thailand's consumer behavior is
changing towards these
um towards the you know these interior
design parts in these segments so
um great insights thank you very much
thank you
so everybody we are about to go to our
our
final speaker um
i would like to introduce you all to mr
marine beige
i hope i pronounced that correctly i'm
sure i did not but i apologize
um mr marine has been uh he's the
founder of
lions design works he founded lion's
design work in 2016
and has been operating uh
internationally so both um
being a dutch uh national native um he's
been uh working from both uh
the netherlands and thailand um he has
also been
the former uh managing and creative
director at jacob jensen design
of the danish firm at king monket
university technologies
school of architecture and design in
thailand uh where he was involved in
formulating their curriculum around
design
he has been the recipient of several
international design awards as well
including the red dot
good design and the iaf product design
award from germany
he has a bachelor design from the design
academy in eindhoven night in the
netherlands
and i would like to give the floor to uh
tomorrow so he can
introduce himself and and also lions
design work and and give us insights on
in thailand
thanks uh you made me flush there a
little bit
thank you very much for a very thorough
big picture overview of what's happening
in the thai creative sector at the
moment
um i'm going to try and
give a little bit more of a very
hands-on
tips and tricks on how foreign creative
agencies can make money in the thai
market
um while keeping in mind
a a global audience now
some of my insights or actually all of
my insights are from
a feron white boy point of view
and i'm an arrogant on the best
today so bear with me there
but i hope that after my
15 minutes there's some key takeaways
from
um from what i'm talking about so i'm
gonna
identify some trends uh in the current
design market
some opportunities that we've identified
for foreign agencies
how to navigate presenting creativity
uh to thai clients or working creatively
with them
and then hopefully at the end like all
right that's real nice marin
but how the hell do we make any money
right now
so i'm not gonna go through these in
order i'm going to show you some of
our products and some of our projects as
examples
and then hopefully you'll uh you'll get
these four points from it
right so a little bit of an intro
udai did a great job but like he said we
are very proud to come
count ourselves among the most
award-winning agencies
in southeast asia and
i run the company i found a company
together with my partner
dana who obviously is the clever one
in our team she has an american
background
and studying computer science and
aerospace engineering
and i'm more classically trained as a
designer so we have a very
complementary skill set that's fun to uh
to apply to the projects we work on
now what we do and this kind of ties
into the first point that i'm trying to
make
is not everything but but a lot
um we do industrial design branding and
lots more and i think this is
our main strength and this is really
what sets us apart in
the thai market and um
ideally the projects that we work on we
actually
get to uh use all our skill sets and all
our expertise on them to create a
better end result so
i know that every single design studio
says on their website we're
multi-disciplinary
but they're not really but a really good
tip um
if you want to get a foothold in the
thai market is
really be multi-disciplinary there is
a big influx in entrepreneurs in this
market
that have a really good idea that they
want to see
come to life but they don't have a
factory
they don't really have the experience
because they either quit their job or
they got laid off from their job and
they really want to make this happen now
and in order to help these people
properly
you need to not just be able to say okay
you know i'll make your id
look good and present the product for
you you have to hold their hand and walk
them through
the entire process from
conceptualization
right up to market launch so as an
example
this is a wristband that dispenses
sanitizing liquid um
this is how it works roughly there's a
pump i'm wearing one right now if you
can see my
my video um
and it comes with a big pump uh which
serves as a refill station
as well now about a year ago
uh was exactly what i just pointed out
there was an entrepreneur he came to us
he had this idea and he's like okay i
have this thing in my head
but i can't put it on paper i can't
visualize it so he asked us
to help us with that which we did we
designed the product the wristband the
bottle
and then we extended we designed his
brand his packaging
and then went on to actually engineering
the thing it's a lot more
complicated than uh than we thought
and we prototyped the whole thing and so
instead of
um our thai client having to hire all
these different agencies
having different quotes paying different
people he can all do it
in house which not just guarantees a
much better end result
it also makes him feel a lot better
we did the back and forth with the
manufacturing we even went so far as to
have our engineers produce the jigs
that the factory workers use to assemble
the wristbands
and then we build his online presence we
designed and built the website and the
e-commerce platform
because a big part of this goes to
charity so we want to be able to control
sales so we build our own e-commerce
platform
so we can you know have a better control
of that
and then we were done and um we wanted
to do
marketing for this product which is not
our biggest expertise at the moment but
we still wanted to be able to do that
in-house with our clients so we
hired a local firm with a great track
record
managed to work with us in
visualizing our design in the best
possible way
[Music]
and working with creators that really
operate
on the same wavelength as us um
is a great way again to
achieve a really good end result now
i think like for let's say i'm a design
firm in singapore
um i have two employees and yeah that
sounds great we want to be truly
multidisciplinary but how the hell do i
do that
like what i just said find a partner
um if you if you work in singapore and
you build websites which is great and
then you get a request from a client
it's like all right we want a website
but we actually want you to design the
product as well
find a partner and and instead of having
it all in-house you can partner with
people and
tackle these problems
[Music]
second point have a real
in-depth process um because
design or branding is not just about a
pretty logo
um and i think there's a lot of
clients that have experiences either
with 99designs
up work where they literally buy a logo
for five dollars
and are unsatisfied with the results so
another opportunity for foreign firms to
work in thailand
is to find businesses uh
foreign owned most of the times but
sometimes thai that are truly
design driven so dot coffee is a coffee
shop
that employs exclusively visually
impaired
or blind baristas and instead of
saying like oh look at the poor blind
people like they can function
in society and say no our coffee is
better
because the baristas are blind and
that was something that really spoke to
us as an agency
so we were very passionate to work with
them but it required
a long and expensive process to get
their brand story properly across
so we did their branding we did their
interior design
we engineered the whole thing this is
when it was built um so the logo
the the three circles is the letter d
and type rail
but then to give you a a quick example
of what
you know there's plenty of agencies both
in thailand but
everywhere in the world that say okay we
can design a great logo for you
like in a week for 10 000 baht
that's not how you create good design
dots coffee was looking for a partner
to find a way to properly communicate
the story that they wanted to tell
so when we presented the three concepts
for their logo to them we actually 3d
printed them so that
the visually impaired people could get
sort of a sense
of where we were trying to take the
company
and i think that's
another great example another
opportunity of how to
leverage your expertise in the thai
market is by saying
yes we do take a long time yes our
process takes
four months and yes we're expensive but
the end result will be a lot better
another example within the same um same
idea
uh this was for a client i mean
obviously it's
an air conditioning unit and you know
it's easy to create great design there's
tons of people that can do it
what makes or breaks good design
is how it looks between when you say to
your client okay here you go
the design is done and when it actually
comes to market it is
always a compromise the back and forth
between
engineering and design is really really
important so initially this is what
this is how we wanted the condensing
unit to look
this is how it looks you know in the end
which is very very different but it
still looks amazing
and a lot of agencies here would be
presenting the design and then leaving
it
to up to up to the client or up to
manufacturing to
get to the end result again hold the
hand of the client
walk with them through the entire
process
in order to create the best end results
let's see if i miss something let me
move on three
um global appeal bringing tightness to
the world this is
by far my favorite category or favorite
point that i'm going to try to make
today
so these are companies
um that you know it's second third
generation
business owners they take over from mom
or dad
they have studied abroad in europe or
america or australia or whatever
and they come back with a much more
design driven approach
of running the company so
they would like to leverage hiring a
design firm whether it's
thai or foreign firm and they understand
the value that that brings not just
in designing the products but also in
the marketing materials saying that
something is designed by lions design
work survive whomever
index is a company that does that very
well
they kind of took the ikea approach
where
they wanted to use european design firms
to sort of boost up their more high-end
furniture line
there's another line with it for them um
another example of that which is
possibly my favorite plant
so this is a thai company that is so
proud of their thai aesthetic
um that they're like no we want to
invest
in taking this aesthetic and expanding
it
for a global audience and they hired us
to do it because it made sense to them
that if you're working for global
audience you should have
a more global with a global
cultural background agency to to do that
for you
and so we had a lot of fun like
identifying
tightness and identifying aesthetic
thai aesthetic and modernizing it and
putting into a line of products that i
can't show because it's confidential but
we did this line of patterning and
better embedding
with it um and this is really really fun
to work on because besides the
multi-disciplinary aspect of it
um these companies are really proudly
tight they're not pretending to be from
the us
or or japanese like some other companies
do here
they're like no we are investing in
taking our aesthetic or taking the thai
aesthetic abroad
by using foreign firms so another
great opportunity there
all right almost done um
a couple of pitfalls so we've had the
opportunities
so what should you be careful let's say
you land a great
thai client um how to navigate these
how to actually make sure that all the
work you put in and all the designs that
you make actually come
to market um this is not actually
just in thailand this happens all over
the world these are just some things
that
in the four years that we've been
operating here
we've run into quite often first
harold this is harold and harold is
a shy engineer harold
says whatever designer commercial comes
off with this is wonderful this is
fantastic
humane is yes i can make this will this
come out of the injection mold this will
absolutely come out of the injection
mold perfectly
don't worry especially when the superior
is in the room
there's no way that harald's gonna say
all right i
i have some issues with with this i
think this will present
some problems so some of the projects
that we
that we've done are stuck in the
engineering phase for
over two years simply because um
the engineers won't say like this is
impossible
or you have to change the design to make
this easier
and so my tip is include the engineers
and don't just include them but get them
excited
from the very beginning whenever we
present even the earliest concepts
a lot of designers are afraid of the
engineers because they're always the
naysayers they're like yeah it's
difficult
get them in the room and get them
excited we're designers it's easy to
present design
it's easy to sell design like you show
it to these engineers it's important
that they feel
proud and proud of working on this
project it'll help you
so much down the line number two
get a proper design brief um
a lot of companies are used to kind of
like a design
on the go approach they hire a cheap
firm
um and they're like oh we want the logo
no no we don't want a logo we want a
website no we don't want a website we
want
new packaging in the end you end up
doing
slice the work for half the money and
then you go out of business
before you start anything get a proper
design brief you're gonna have to make
it yourself that's fine
sit down with the client read between
the lines and
make sure that you truly understand what
it is that you
actually want
lastly design for all the stakeholders
this is possibly the most important one
remember i talked about
you know second third generation
business owners
i guarantee you that grandma who ran the
company
30 years ago still has a lot of
decision-making power so even though you
never meet grandma
you'll never get an email from grandma
if you present the design she'll see it
and if
even if the guy you're talking to your
contact person the guy who studied
abroad in amsterdam perhaps
he loves it and he wants to move forward
with it if grandma doesn't like it
it's not going to come to market make
sure or at least do your best
to find out who all the stakeholders are
and try
and design for all of them not just for
the young guy across the table
so making money like
please right now because it's covered
and we could all use it
um it's kind of hard but like my last
slide
and and my takeaway and i feel like i've
i've touched this already
um it's collaborating it's working
together
as creative agencies i know that covet
has this old boxed in
and we can't move across borders and it
sucks and we can't travel
but what coven has also done is
kind of taken down the communication
barriers
both clients and other agencies are very
comfortable
working over zoom now we're having this
webinar over zoom now i usually stand up
in front of an audience
the big opportunity here which actually
already happened
um we started working with a japanese
design firm who would be a competitor
they knew exactly what we do
but they had a big client in southeast
asia they couldn't fulfill the contract
because they couldn't travel
so they work together with us to
deliver this great end result and i
think
that's the way to move forward find
find other creative agencies that are on
the same wavelength as you
and work together it could it could work
both ways um
like if somebody is in china and they
have
a product design client in thailand they
could work with us and then
that would work the other way around as
well and
i really think at least in the near
future
this is how um how we're gonna get
through this
as creative agencies together
look at that all right that's it um
if you want to know more well i think
there's a question around now but you
can
uh follow me on instagram and send me
some more questions there
and i hope this uh this gave some good
insights in
how you could benefit from the thai
market at the moment
brilliant marine thank you so much uh
that was a brilliant
and straight to the point uh insights on
how to engage with the
not just clients in thailand but also um
you know with partners so thank you so
much for
for that thank you so much for your time
as well um everybody that's um we're
almost to the end
um what we would like to do now is do a
very quick poll for all the uh all the
attendees
um about uh the business of design
program
um as well as uh the thailand market
so uh please uh look at your
zoom screens um and uh go ahead and
give us your uh your poll there will
give you
one minute i think that should be good
enough
while these uh while zoom calculates
these uh these these uh poll numbers
uh we will now have a few words from the
design
singapore council team so mabel um
why don't you uh share your slides and
and we can have a quick overview of the
business
design program as well and um
and then we can uh conclude this session
with our with our question answer
session
okay hi thanks thanks judy and thanks
everyone for taking the time to join us
for today's webinar
so um as judy has mentioned i'd like to
take this opportunity to share a little
bit more about the business of design
program
so um the body program aims to grow the
export
value of singapore designs through
building mindshare in both business to
business and business to consumer
markets around the world
this two year long program will address
targeted aspects of developing the
capabilities of participating design
firms
this includes mentorship access to
networks and brand storytelling
as well as to increase their competitive
and demand on the global stage
the second run of the bud program aims
to generate new business opportunities
for up to eight
to internationalize in markets such as
europe and asia including japan and
southeast asia
to grow businesses and propel them
globally the beauty program encompasses
three key
phases the first phase dsg will appoint
a panel of in-market consultants to
guide design studios and brands in their
pitch
to secure business opportunities
overseas
the control the consultants will also
connect them to relevant business
circles while providing mentorship for
follow-through
these business circles leads include
property owners
and specifiers for those who are seeking
commercial contract projects
brands and manufacturers for those who
are seeking consultancy projects
and global or regional retailers and
distributors for those seeking buyers
these consultants will be selected based
on their networks and influence
and are expected to have convertible
business leads in these markets
the second phase of the program
comprises participants potentially being
provided funding
to engage a brand strategy agency
this will help to enforce the exception
of their brand as well as to facilitate
strong veterans for participating
science
lastly the beauty program will culminate
in a themed collective showcase that an
established international showcase
platform
in 2022 working with the in-market
consultants this approach will raise the
international standing of singapore
design
and interest buyers from
markets in asia and europe
to support interested design firms that
are interested um they're keen to
internationalize
in understanding the commitment required
to enter these markets dsg is
co-organizing a series of market entry
webinars including today's session
in addition to the beauty program these
webinars are also part of an ongoing
effort to provide resources to the
singapore design community
the open call for body participants is
currently open and will close
on thursday 22 april let me just run
through quickly um
the eligibility and selection criteria
for the brd program
so in terms of the eligibility criteria
the applicant must be a singapore
registered design enterprise from any of
the following fields
furniture and lifestyle product design
studios multi-disciplinary design
studios that incorporate furniture and
livestock product design
as well as design driven furniture and
all lifestyle product
lifestyle product brand owners um the
lead app
must also be super citizen or
a permanent resident prioritizes
established design studios and brands
which fulfill the following criteria
having a compelling and differentiated
brand philosophy and aspiring towards
good design
which impacts positively on the
environment culture society or the
economy
having strong business fundamentals and
being ready to scale up to meet
international demand
which and in doing so the participant
must for example operate with a sound
business model
and have sufficient resources to be able
to scale through a network of production
partners for instance
lastly having a good understanding of
the commitment required to enter
a new market so that's why we are having
these series of webinars and also
encouraging participants
potential applicants to also attend
these webinars
for the markets that they're interested
in
so i hope this sharing provides a good
idea for the business
design program is about uh send it back
over to ud
perfect thank you uh thank you mabel for
for those of the information i'm pretty
sure that the singapore design firms
will find that useful
i would also like to follow that up with
just a very very brief
piece of information on enterprise
singapore's grants
so if you're a singaporean sme whether
you're design firm or not
enterprise singapore offers uh something
called the market readiness
assistance grant uh and this is to help
companies internationalize
and usually from our experience we see a
lot of small to medium
enterprises apply for this when they're
looking to go to thailand
or enter the market like vietnam for
example so
um you know don't be shy reach out to
the
enterprise singapore uh team um you can
get more information on the enterprise
singapore website i've linked i've
put the link over there and also you
know you have
sme centers um all across singapore so
uh feel free to um to look at that link
sme center sicci dot sg
and connect with your local sme center
who can take you through that process
for applying for a grant if you're
looking to um either collaborate with
somebody in in a different
uh market yeah or you're looking to
start something
um in in the region so um
thank you for that with that we have uh
finished
our uh all the information that we want
to provide to the to the audience and i
think we'll open the floor
for question and answers um the
interesting thing from the poll
is that about 93 of you have voted so
that's great
um the first question was you know are
you keen to apply for the design
singapore
business of design program um and about
36 percent
uh of those who voted said yes and um 11
have said no
i believe there's half of you who've uh
who are undecided but you know i think
if you have more information from the uh
from the design singapore team uh you
might change your mind
and uh finally our other question was
you know are you keen to enter the time
market to do business and we've got
an overwhelming majority um who said yes
around 80 percent
uh of our uh attendees have said they're
very keen to enter the market so
uh very good to know that and i'm i i
hope this this session has been
insightful um for for everybody now
we'll open this up for
question and answers um and i will
direct the questions
to uh to the to the different panelists
so i believe
the first question today is for kun
chutes um
and the question is from mr simon u and
the question is you know how do the
different
geographic regions in thailand actually
differ to each other
um if you could uh
if you could answer that or the other
panelists as well please
feel free to uh to pitch in there sure
um culturally also
you know geographically different and
also it's also different
culturally can you hear them can you
hear me
yes yes we can hear you okay yes um
basically you know the central plain
it's
what is kind of known to the outside as
what thailand is that's a very still
stereotype thailand
um and then the north region has a bit
more influence from the burmese
and the indian culture um
basically you know even the rice in
different regions
is different you know the north and the
north east uh
the north east uh eats um sticky rice
while the central plain in the south is
more of the
kind of like the white plain plain rice
as we know
um so you know
by different geographies its culture is
very different even in the northeast
itself it's divided into two zones
kind of like the two basin with a
kind of like a mountain area in the
middle that divided it
um and that geography also makes
different cultures like the northern
basin house conicon
basin has you know kind of like a salt
as a native so have like the salted fish
it's kind of like they made products
there which
affect you know how they cook and how
they behave and
what they eat or what they grow so
you know it's a very widespread question
it's
it's almost like if i can compare it um
easily it's like when we eat ramen in
japan
from one village to another sometimes if
you are from an outsider you don't know
that it is different
but if you study it carefully you know
one village would
maybe use the the broth from the
backbone
while the next village will use the
broth from the lake moon only
that's also very true in thailand is
that one village to another
you know the culturally is different
even though it's the islam dialect you
know that they speak
they would speak in a slightly different
tone and that makes the design market
slightly different and what needs
in certain region will be different from
certain regions
me basis mostly as an architect when we
and i work all over the country all
southeast asia
is that um
it it takes a bit of time to really
understand the culture
to be able to design the house that
fits your clients specific needs um
carefully um and you know to fit it well
to
fit that lifestyle so so
you know you need to be a good observer
basically
great thank you so much for uh for
answering that simon i hope we have
answered your question
uh the next question is from jerry who
asks to i believe all the panelists
could you please provide a list or or
some suggestions of outstanding design
schools in thailand particularly in
architecture
interior design or product design so
maybe we can go one by one
um because the obvious do you have any
suggestions well
july lumborn of course is a big one
for architecture school i think if you
want to become
a thinker but in that program that i
taught
is probably the best program there you
won't come out
knowing how to design a building but you
will come out
knowing um you know what the
kind of like the the the edge of the
architecture research
um is at the moment and i would suggest
that you go to
get your master's at you know you know
columbia or yale or something a bit more
practical
you know got it thank you yeah and uh
how about
uh you uh marine or kunsan anything on
on interior design or
product design any any specific
suggestions for
uh institutions in thailand yeah i think
well um i think
the best design schools in the world
have a habit where the teachers
are actual professionals they have their
own studio their famous computers four
days a week
and then they teach one day a week very
practical
giving giving uh hands-on lectures on
not just how to design but also how to
sell design
and you know right up until how do you
file patent registration
i think that there is a lot of design
schools
in thailand that are great um that we
some of the
designers that that work on our team
have been to um i think a much more
important factor in choosing a design
school
is uh you know the classes that you
elect
there's some some ways that some things
you can focus on while you're in school
whether it's
model building or branding or you know i
really want to do product design but i
also want to do
ux um i think it's up to the student to
kind of
their own curriculum beyond what is
offered um
in thailand in a more conservative way
perfect thank you anything to add there
concerning rap from an interior design
perspective
um no not really i agree with both
great thank you so much um i think we
have a final question here
uh from stanley yap um and he's
directing this towards me uh
uh could you please elaborate on the
need for technology and innovation
in the thai industry any specific
examples um he
stanley further on further says you know
for single point design firms or
advertising firms
interested in entering the time market
um can we approach ca directly for
advice or
you know if yes who should be right into
so um i think
um thai companies don't spend enough on
r d i mean let's be honest is that and
i think that the lack of r d
make us weak in technologies
so you know it's a very broad
technology needs really that that needs
to be
you know kind of like with that that we
need assistance in thailand
all our heavy industries
are from adapt technologies basically
we you know we have car assembly factory
but we don't have
you know our own car company um
that's slightly changed at the moment
with electric
cars that there are thai companies
who are trying to
[Music]
um innovate and invent their own
technologies
into this new frontier
though of course being
you know kind of like the new sort of
business trend even for large
corporation in thailand
um we already you know 20 years behind
let's say tesla or you know even
some chinese company and so
you know that sort of yeah i mean to be
specific you know
i mean the biggest thing i think you can
enter thailand right now
um probably has to do with this mobility
issue there will be a lot of money
invested
in that industry for the next
you know 10 years and
when we talk about big money of course
it's still very small compared to
what we get in the north east up
from from the us or from you know
european
investment or even chinese investment
so but yeah but that business is
definitely starting
um for singaporean design advertising
firm
into entertainment yes you can directly
contact cea um i think the best way to
do it
is to contact via our
info email so it's info ca dot
o r dot th and then your questions will
be
directly back uh to the right person
via that uh information it's very
actively answered
so that would be the best email to
contact great thank you so much um
stanley i hope
that has answered your question uh
everybody i think uh we are we are now
at the uh
at the end of our session uh we've gone
a 20 minutes overboard so thank you
everybody for
for staying online um if you have any
other questions
uh please do write in to us um or the
singapore
the design singapore council team and uh
and then we can pass it on to um
to our panelists and speakers here uh uh
dear speakers
solicop and uh thank you very much for
your time
thank you thank you thank you
oh before we go uh one final thing uh
please do
scan this qr code this is all this for
the attendees um
post webinar survey uh so please do scan
this and and give us your
give give the design singapore council
your your feedback
maybelline team if you have any any
final words to say please uh please go
ahead
otherwise we can wrap up the session
nope uh thanks everyone for attending
the webinar
today and thank you to the speakers as
well
thank you great marine thank you very
much
hey guys
you